you're about to start Lesson Four in the
mini course again I'm Alex lion and if
you haven't yet subscribed I encourage
you to do so and check the rest of the
videos on the channel out on this
particular video like the last one some
people don't like a couple of the tips
because if you fall in this category you
might feel like well that's a lot of
structure and I don't normally
communicate that way well that's true
not everybody communicates in a
structured orderly way but it is one of
the best ways to sound more concise
clear and confident so give it a try
check your selft talk and motivation why
is it that you don't want to communicate
this way because if you can get to the
bottom of your inner thoughts then
you're much more likely to succeed and
communicate in a clear fashion so let's
Jump Right
[Music]
In in our last lesson we looked at
concise statements and in Lesson Four
we're going to look at organized
thoughts concise tip number four
organize your thoughts into clear points
this is of course one way to remain
concise but it also adds an incredible
amount of clarity and confidence to your
message messages without a clear
structure are very hard to follow for
your listeners and long lists dilute
each item's value you've probably sat
through presentations where somebody had
20 items or on a list and there's really
no impact there when you have that many
items much better to create fewer clear
points a clear organization shows clear
confident thinking
here we have a messy desk and a joke I
pulled from a comic if you think this is
bad you should see the inside of my head
this actually looks a little bit like my
desk and I'm all for creativity however
once we're sharing our thoughts with
somebody else once we're communicating
we really have to stay more structured
so that they can follow along with what
we're saying in a clear and
understandable way Richard fean said it
like this if you can't expl exp it to a
six-year-old you really don't understand
it and the idea here is that if you
really understand something you can
explain it in a very clear and
structured way for your listeners they
talk about being able to give a freshman
lecture on a concept and if you can't
give a freshman level lecture then you
don't yourself understand it so this
structure will help us clarify our own
thoughts and help it land for other
people structure provides a schema or a
mental framework that helps keeps
thoughts clear for you helps your
listeners follow your point it gives
your message cohesion or an overarching
arc and it helps everybody
remember strategy one is to break
messages into two to three chunks for
example let's say you're having a
conversation about getting healthy and
you want to share this information with
somebody else instead of just rambling
you want to break it down into clear
points for example you could talk about
diet exercise and the importance of
working out with a friend and underneath
each of those themes or some people call
them buckets you would give your details
so if you're talking about diet you
might talk about counting calories or
Weight Watchers Etc under exercise the
different options and under working out
with a friend how you would hold each
other a little accountable for staying
on track I was talking to a friend of
mine and this is a real life example and
I talked about his retirement plan he's
retired and he said 401k I have some
rental income and a little bit of Social
Security instead of giving a long-
winded disorganized rambling answer he
was able to give me clear themes and
then we continued the discussion about
each of these three items and he
provided some nice detail I was watching
a movie about a disabled man from Ghana
many years ago and he had one good leg
and one disabled leg and he finally got
a meeting with a community leader and
the leader said what are your priorities
and he said I want to help provide
Independence mobility and Sports for the
disabled people in Ghana he had just a
moment to break the ice with an
extremely clear message and to this day
I remember this documentary film that he
communicated in that clear and confident
way and I instantly thought wow this guy
really knows what he's talking about
when we do this we want to organize our
chunks our main points into some logical
pattern a nice logical pattern is going
to help people remember and it's going
to clarify our thoughts for ourselves
before after problem solution benefit
cause and effect steps in a sequence or
in other words chronological Etc lots of
different options here you're not
limited to this list but it's nice to
have a list handy for example let's
practice with this stream of thought
example about somebody's day I got up
got ready ate breakfast and worked out I
did some shopping on the way home from
the gym I bumped into Katie at the store
she wants to get together tonight I
actually got some work done during the
day shot some videos did some editing
and organized the tools in the garage I
was hoping to get together with Katie
and John tonight but I also have some
people to get back to some calls to make
or at least a couple of texts to stay on
top of some things so this sounds a
little bit like rambling but you can
basically follow it it's much more clear
however if we structure this into main
points for example chronologically
morning afternoon and evening and each
of those items has a few details
underneath it those themes provide a
really great way to clarify your message
make it much more concise and it'll
sound very confident compared to a
rambling disorganized message it's handy
to have a list like this around when
you're preparing for meetings important
conversations and certainly
presentations because you don't have to
create this from scratch you can invent
new ways but there are lots of great
schemas already available for
structuring your ideas
strategy number two is to then State
your road map so you have your structure
and now you want to forecast those
points aloud with key words only so a
physician might say to you let's talk
about symptoms and then treatments now
you have a road map for how that
conversation is going to go and I
recommend also calling out your points
along the way so let's say you start
with symptoms you talk about that for a
few minutes and if you're the physician
then you might say now let's turn to
your treat
options and that'll be a really clear
signal that you're shifting gears and it
again reminds people of that schema
reminds them of your buckets and it
helps your message stay
clear so structure provides Freedom even
though it seems like it boxes people in
we go back to mindset that we talked
about in the earli lesson on
long-windedness why are we long-winded
sometimes people resist applying
structure because it feels too
restrictive it feels like it's robbing
them of something but there are a lot of
benefits and there are freedoms that you
can experience within a good structure
first of all it eliminates tangents
which is good for your thinking and it's
good for listeners they don't want to
hear tangents anymore than you want to
get off on them but it also provides a
place for more details so if you have
clear main points then you can find some
nice details and sort them into the
relevant place and then they'll make
sense and it gives even long stories a
sense of cohesion so let's say you tell
a 5 minute story that it's disorganized
it's going to feel like it lasts forever
if you tell a 5 minute story with clear
beginning middle and end then everybody
will be able to follow it and it won't
feel long at all so structure is a tool
to help you sort need to know
information versus nice to know
information we talked about this in an
earlier lesson if it doesn't fit into
your structure either you have the wrong
structure the wrong main points or it's
just not need to know information it
might be just something that's nice to
know which is why it doesn't fit in and
that way when you communicate with
listeners you're giving them high value
information with every
sentence so we want to organize our
thoughts into clear points our takeaway
strategies are to break ideas into two
to three chunks and then State your road
map really clearly before you share your
message and then remind people of your
points As you move through them so our
task is to apply this in conversations
meetings and presentations that you have
coming up in the coming days
and I look forward to seeing you in the
next lesson on effective pauses